-Welcome back, everybody. We are
hanging out with Queen Latifah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-Wow.
-We are about to play
"The Whisper Challenge."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whisper Challenge.
-Oh, wow.
Here's how the game works.
One person puts on
these headphones
with loud music playing.
And then the other person
picks up a card,
reads the random phrase
on that card,
and the person
wearing the headphones
has to try and guess what
they just said.
Queen Latifah, you're my guest.
Please put on these headphones
first.
-Oh, my God.
-These are soundproof.
Where's your left?
-I see you.
I have a pair of those. They
really are noise-canceling.
-Right? These are the --
You can do this at home.
Do I have it right? Yeah, left.
Okay, ready?
I'm going to put on some jams.
Alright.
You can't hear nothing.
-How am I supposed concentrate
with that on?!
-Okay. Here we go. Perfect.
Alright. Ready?
Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
I just make you laugh just
by looking at you.
Hallmark card.
-Hallmark card.
-What?! Yes!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's called chemistry.
You can't buy that!
-Oh, my God.
-Hallmark card.
How did you get that?
Wow! That's fantastic!
You know me so well.
-I hope I'm as good as you are.
-I think we're going to be great
at this.
Come on. I can't believe --
That's never happened.
-That's a lot of time in a club
when you can't hear.
[ Laughter ]
Got to get that number.
So, do I take this one?
Okay. He's jamming.
He's jamming. He's rocking.
Oh, this is hard.
Seven-layer dip.
-Cellphone. Cellphone.
-Seven --
-Selfie.
-No.
-Selfie stick.
-Seven --
-Enough is enough!
-Layer.
[ Laughter ]
-Take it off.
-Seven-layer dip.
-Cafe level up. Level up.
Next level.
-Seven layer dip.
-New down up. Down up.
You jump. Jump around.
-Seven.
Seven.
-Never.
Never.
-Seven.
Layer.
-Leather.
Leather.
-Layer.
-Sleep, nappie.
Oh, you wake up.
-Layer.
-You wake up.
-Throw your hands.
Sounds like air.
-And your hair's on the pillow.
Hair.
-Layer.
This is not going to work.
Seven --
-Stefan.
-Wait, one, two, three,
four, five, six...
-One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
-Seven.
-Seven!
-Layer dip.
-Seven.
-Seven-layer dip.
-Letter up.
-Seven eat it up.
-Seven-layer --
-What is it?
-Seven-layer dip!
-Oh, my gosh, come on!
[ Sad tuba ]
Of course.
What other time of the year do
you talk about seven-layer dip?
-This is like the only time.
-I don't do seven-layer dip.
Too many layers for me.
Six too many layers for me.
-It's so good, too.
-You do one layer and I'm good.
Seven-layer dip.
You can't make it all the way
down there.
-This is hard.
-That was a hard one. I'm sorry.
-This was a hard one.
-Hallmark card was easy.
Alright, here we go. Sorry.
Did I pause it?
-Oh, snap.
-Alright, ready?
-Okay.
I'm going back in the club.
Alright. Hey, hey.
I'm never going to get it.
I know it. I can tell.
-Swedish fish.
-Swisher fish.
[ Laughter ]
Swedish fish?
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, snap! What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
What?
-How did -- I've never --
-How did they know?
-In my life, I've never
in my life.
-Are you serious?
-I almost want to stop here.
Do I have to go again?
-Oh, my God!
-That is the best anyone's
ever done.
-That is crazy.
-I was like, "You're never going
to get Swedish fish."
-I love Swedish fish.
-Me too. I love Swedish fish.
Oh, my God.
-I was like,
"What's a swisher fish?"
-Swisher fish.
-Okay.
-Okay, this is
for all the marbles.
-Alright, Dana, do a good job.
-Come on.
-Unify this. This is me?
-That's you, I think.
That's it.
-♪ U-N-I-T-Y ♪
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ U-N-I-T-Y ♪
Queen Latifah!
"Unity in the Community"
is available exclusively on
Audible.
And "The Equalizer" airs Sundays
at 8:00 p.m. on CBS
and streaming on Paramount+.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.